confusion really clearly in the way that
this new law was
set up in the first place because it has
led to some inequalities according to
the national police chiefs council
and that's why they have had to take the
step now writing
to forces right across the country to
say
do not use fixed penalty
notices again for this 10 000 pounds
fine
and instead go to a system of
introducing court summonses
they've issued a statement just within
the last few minutes
to as they say that on friday the 13th
of november we advised all forces to
temporarily take enforcement steps
by way of summons rather than by issuing
a fixed penalty notice to the value of
10 000 pounds
for offenses relating to gatherings of
over
30 people under covert regulations it
goes on to say
we gave this advice of a potential
disparity between those
who opt to pay by the fixed penalty
notice
and those who see their case reach court
where the fixed penalty notice
would be means tested against personal
income so
in plain english effectively what's
happening
is that uh those who are being issued
with this fixed penalty notice
for ten thousand a significant number of
these people
are perfectly understandably deciding
that they want to appeal
this very hefty fine now in appealing it
it goes through the court process
and then of course it's up to a
magistrate in court looking
at all of the issues here uh defendant
their background their means uh how much
income they have coming in etc
uh can decide that ten thousand pounds
of a fixed penalty
is just too much for this person to pay
and either reduce the fine or give them
a longer period
of time in which to pay that 10 000
pounds fine so
clearly pretty embarrassing for the
government the reason that this
fixed penalty notice of up to ten
thousand
pounds was introduced in the first place
was to give
the police more powers to tackle what
was
growing and it still is an emerging
problem during lockdown which is
these organized events mass gatherings
raves and other streets and parties that
are taking place with people of more
than 30
in number gathering it gives the police
then an option
to hand out pretty hefty fines for those
organizers
as a means of deterring them from doing
that kind of activity but now
it seems that certainly according to the
national police chiefs council
it's not at all clear the way in which
this fixed penalty notice system
is operating so they're saying suspend
it don't issue any more fixed penalties
you can still go through the process but
you have to do it
by means of a court summons instead in
the meantime
the national police chief's council is
urgently trying to address the matter
with the home office with the view to
coming up with a more permanent fix to
this it may be
that going forward we see a system
whereby
the fixed penalty is noticed but it's
made very clear to
a person receiving that fine that they
can appeal through the courts process
that might be
a way forward to do this in proper
legislation but it's obviously
embarrassing as i say this was a key
plank of law enforcement
going forward as we entered this second
lockdown to give
law enforcement authorities an option to
clamp down on these mass gatherings